the line is the earth is still worth
saving okay three two one go don't speak
it don't sing it you're literally being
destroyed by optimist okay it's an
action movie not a musical yeah
no it's disrespectful and don't sing
when I'm talking to you can you speak
they find outer space okay go call Mel
that's not good to get mounted on Tisha
I'm really big ulis how much was back
with the trance ball it's just for
eyeline
just pretend it's Josh oh I'm here
around I don't mind read with you you
got the real deal okay we'll see you in
no thanks I'll stick with the tennis
ball okay I'll be right over here
what swimmers they still like ya it's
kind of a tricky chair this should be
easy
if I want to fold it out its unfurl it
honey wait a minute transform the chair
I'll just and Prez wonders the last
night it's a London dialect it should
sound like this this before dishonor
yes before dishonor no no no what the
King death before dishonor
oh no what death before dishonor this
lesson could be your very last if you
threaten my life one more time today I'm
in my car and I'm off hope then go home
you